[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
breaking news we can now call the
presidency for jessica clemons yeah i
can't run for president all right
welcome back to the break room you
pieces of absolute garbage our daily
show
quiet silence keeps you updated on all
the nerdy news that you need to know so
much coming up in the world we have dc
news i am groot talk and getting jacked
in two weeks oh man must be the tom
bechtold story let's introduce our other
hosts all the way to my left the man who
carries much
emotional heft erica wusu
hey internet how y'all doing and seated
at the left hand of the father
everyone's favorite daughter step
daughter
jessica clement
step daughter
i don't like where this is going i can
see it through my right man who keeps it
nice and tight oh it's called your dream
let's do it that's right jack in two
weeks we're gonna change
your life for the worst and let me tell
you you spend a lot of time on the john
all right
we've got a very fun redemption today
something i'm really jazzed about guys
in honor of our favorite cute little
floral colossus we've got an i am groot
swear jar translation okay what does
that mean you might be asking i'll tell
you right now for every 50
we raise in the super chats one of us is
going to release a tirade of swears in
groot speak
luckily
each one of us here is fluent in groot
speak so we will translate for you okay
so for instance if jessica says
i am group i say she's saying you're all
a bunch of trashy [ __ ] okay that's
that's the translation those are
jessica's words not mine
reminder
the break room is on tick tock baby
that's right we're at the underscore
break room follow us for even more break
room content
this thing's killing me
you said it was electrical
oh no it's accelerating okay i think
there's a button on the side that you
can press i am i'm pressing it
all right things have gone off the road
mom and dad aren't fighting guys don't
worry now jessica yes why don't you take
us down a little section of the street
we call headline alley
wait did you play the graphic i can't
tell you oh there it is
he's
says that season 3 is off the chain whoa
dear god like a 60 year old man saying
something's off the chain the thing is
every time i think of dark color
esposito the first thing i think of is
school days the spike lee joint
and do the right thing so i'm okay with
him saying off the chain but then if you
think of the modern general like i see i
think i'm like malcolm x and was like
that's a weird thing for him to say why
would you say that well because because
he's like so badass in that movie but no
no no he wouldn't he wouldn't draw john
carlo say that yeah no no no i meant no
i mean i thought i was like why the hell
is i'm so sorry
listen i'm gonna go ahead and release a
tirade i am groot all right now
go ahead oh my god i think you just said
i'm a [ __ ]
no not to you i saw the love of
said i gotta tell you just to share
something with you without spoiling
anything as one does season three of the
mandalorian is off the chain you'll be
amazed i like that what if they just
break dance
it's a rap music video uh the dc films
president walter armada reported uh
reportedly had plans to include the
crisis on
an infinite earth event rumors
circulated about introducing the secret
six a villain team that in the comics
have been suicide squad's antagonist uh
the warner's had films based on
supergirl coming green lantern court uh
and static shock expected in the next
few years plus a jj abrams produced
black superman film from the writer
tanishi coates
development has slowed with none of
those features attaching directors um i
i low-key forgot that there was a static
shock coming yeah and jordan producing
was it i didn't know i i read it yes
yeah i was wrong
i i love mcduffie so much and i love the
show that i was like oh i'm so excited
i'll be honest i wasn't really hyped
when dc took it on but maybe they could
come back from it um static shock was so
good and i just don't want you to do it
poorly again we need static shock done
justly
and thusly and thusly while i'm thrustly
peacemaker season 2 and multiple james
gunn projects reported moving forward at
dc the hollywood reporter mentions james
gunn having multiple projects in
development at dc including season two
of peacemaker um what else he told us
that he didn't want to be the next like
zack snyder right he said like
outwardly he was like please don't give
me that i don't want to be stuck over
please okay i'll do it okay i'll do
seven scenes okay fine he's like i'm
doing peacemaker plus i have a million
other projects and he just wrapped up uh
guardians now on marvel so i'm like are
you just gonna i think what he should do
is like play both sides still but then
sneak in like high budget indies where
he's just like hey you want me to come
back you're gonna fund this 80 million
dollar thing piece for my class there
you go
he's making so much money off that that
he could just he could just coast off
that because i love when and like you
know the name's not as good right now
but like joss whedon when he made that
shakespeare adaptation that would never
come without
and that's a great adaptation of much
about nothing no one would have funded
that without avengers yeah so it'd be
cool if james gunn was like i'm gonna
make this troma movie because like you
know there's those weird things he loves
to be great to have here you gotta start
with the old lloyd kaufman that crazy
mfa
crazy crazy i am grooter
hey i love strong words and the same
article blue beetle is still planning to
be uh to move forward all right um the
actor
is dc's first latino superhero the top
line of movie is also on track for its
august 2023 release
will it be pushed probably
that's like like
some press as of right now if i was a
betting man i'd put the house on
that date nice thing yes yeah yeah i
don't think that date is gonna well
maybe they'll shock us and become
incredibly efficient and accurate all of
a sudden dc stuff comes out it's great
like it comes out on time yeah under
budget the missing piece was disney
there was a discovery this whole time
that's right and when was the last time
uh a superhero film was actually like
projected to come out on this date and
then showed up on that date i don't
remember pre-pandemic for sure
it's not a superhero film but i feel
like the at the sec after the pandemic
delay ghostbusters was released around
oh yeah on the day they the first time
they re-announced its date after its
initial pending it actually showed up on
the channel it's just so there's so many
variables it's so hard because like
setting a date five years ago was like
oh let's look around three years ago it
was like okay what if someone moves
cascading effect and then ends up two
years ago it was like our lead got sick
for ten days everything's on fire yeah
cause like you can't control that many
people's variables there was a time
right when uh um
uh keanu reeves had like three movies
coming out on the same day her vote was
supposed to be like matrix john wick and
billy and ted we're all like within the
same like span i believe all right
kate caitlyn martinez gets us to the
group square i'm just going to make this
easy eric you're releasing the tirade
i will translate for you all right all
right here we go
i am groot our entire audience is trash
keep going i am groot
stinky shitty trash i
am gross you all have bastard trash
mouths i am groot and you live in
dumpsters where you both sleep in your
feces and also
eat barf god damn i am gr
that's all i got to say about you mother
efforts
i censored the last one because you know
come on it's early in the show the thing
is he's so happy while saying that it
makes me uncomfortable yeah it's true as
group it's true oh yeah that's true
that's true
uh the black adam has a new post-credits
scene added to ty black adam to the dceu
the october 21st release for dwayne
johnson's black adam that film had a
june test screening including a new
post-credit scene introducing a new
element to johnson's place in the dc
universe do you think this code you mean
shazam
okay look here look here
look a new element attire it is what
he's in the comics about like it's so
because they had like adam as an
unspoken and then spoken part of shazam
where it was like that guy in the chair
and then like it was pretty much and now
at the comic con they had them
side by side and then didn't have any
crossover it was so strange that shazam
and black adam literally shared a stage
and didn't really acknowledge 100 i
think they should make shazam 3 or black
adam to that crossover right like i
think i think honestly the way they
should reintroduce the dc universe is
have certain films like we talked about
disparate and certain films connected
and i think black adam and shazam should
stay their own little corner that way
the rock has the freedom to make the
rock movies i just feel like it's so
weird for them to just can you scroll
back up really quick i think it's so
weird of them to be like
we added this new element just recently
when shazam has always been on track
that's
wrong maybe that's why i'm like it might
be something
it's the new superman
fight superman and it's like some guy
i hope it's michael keaton
but he's just playing michael keaton and
he's like i'm supposed to be in one of
these goddamn movies
somebody which one is it he just shows
up watch him give me a suit yeah he just
puts on whatever super suit of the day
vulture give me birdman
i would love for michael keaton to just
show up randomly to a set where the
producers for different superhero movies
are and they're like michael keaton and
he's like so which which scene am i in
what is this i just want the amalgam
universal michael keaton plays eight
characters i want the dc marvel
crossover just for money the thing is if
you say it enough and the internet
follows we will get it because i i
always thought it sony he was going to
be gathering the sinister six which they
alluded to and then in dc it looked like
before backer was canceled he was going
to be gathering the new justice league
yeah so i love the idea that michael
keaton's like nick fury but not nick
fury but also could be nick fury yeah
yeah don't make him
i think you know what guys it's time to
make nick fury
michael keaton okay there's one thing
i'm just kidding don't don't do it don't
do it we're so sorry
uh
we don't need any more evidence come on
black canary standalone movie thank you
for pointing at me
still development hbo max i'm the big
board on the big board
show put it in the
not being developed yes i told you to
turn around
i threw it
that was your one major this is all i
really want me and i'm so happy for you
i'm very happy for me we're all excited
because everything no everybody knows as
long as they say it's still in
development it's definitely gonna happen
with this very stable
very uh clearly know what they want to
do company right now okay so don't worry
about it everyone just keeps staring off
into the sunset okay you moving against
it
eric voss's head shot in anger
i've never been so humiliated my
favorite part is also my voice crack
because i'm going through puberty my
favorite part is also the fact that like
they dc now like the warner brothers
discovery has now been like we're not
gonna let anything fly that doesn't that
shouldn't fly like they're like picky
and choosy about what they want and so
this is yeah this is in development so
it's truly like we can make it good i
know we can and then
we we'll see i'm really curious how
they're going to keep some characters
and redo others like so black canary has
been introduced in conceptually the
greater snyder universe like not saying
it's a snyder film but because snyder
used some of those characters and then
birds of prey had heard like does that
not equal yeah whereas blue beetle i
assumed was still going because they
don't have to have that tie to anything
how do you half reboot the universe hmm
they're gonna do it if you get a
question
you're the president's right here yeah
so uh when we do this crisis film does
some universes survive is an incursion
event this is what we do we introduce
some characters
uh and keep some characters who have
been with us much like the james bond
film yes
drinking president for that judy dench
was m for chris brosnan and for daniel
craig and so alfred go as butler uh you
know alfred or michael go as the butler
alfredo in the old batman films
president precisely i know and who could
forget the oh sorry what were you going
to say the way we burn money
yes
and spoil contracts here's the james
bond model that just keeps superman just
to suit yes who knows who's above that
head
and remember they shepherded us that way
through the aladdin cinematic universe
when robin williams left after the first
one was replaced by dan castellaneta the
voice of homer simpson however iago was
voiced by gilbert godfrey in all those
movies he never left and the cartoon
project that's right and the animated
series good point i just learned
something today oh my god i think eric
that was an excellent that's the perfect
example the james bond movies are how
you how you get out of this thank you i
need that presidential ceo uh hbo
discovery money immediately i need the
chat we're getting my own today
absolutely let's get a geconomy's check
uh we are getting super chats
galore i pray today's redeem is ice
cream you clearly weren't listening it's
i am groot screams
okay it's groot screams ice cream groot
screams we all scream for groot for
groot okay
okay
my voice keeps cracking marvel studios
didn't give thor's hercules enough time
for uh the mcu training if you guys know
actors you know they train very hard and
by their diets are insane uh but the one
playing hercules he said yeah when i
spoke to taika i said you know i'm
basically like a skinny comedian i said
when is this filming it was like in two
weeks and i was like i mean i'll do my
best but two weeks feels i said he
doesn't have to be uh as big as thor
does he and look on the day i mean i'm
doing 400
that day i was fit to explode i did the
best i could on the day yeah
i respect that breaking through those
400 push-ups i do is it immediate
results in bad shavings
yeah he has to be pretty fit to play uh
roy kent right yeah
but like soccer fit is very like like
you don't want to talk yeah
that cardio is different so like if
you're playing if you're playing a
soccer player you look like this that's
a problem but so the issue for him is
like he's standing next to maybe the
fittest dude in hollywood right now yeah
like if by the time we get hercules
versus thor hope he has more information
don't worry now we have redeemed another
groot swear tangent i'm gonna go ahead
and say uh koi you're going to do the
groot squares this time okay jessica you
will interpret what koi is saying uh
because you speak rude as well from what
i've been told yes i did it two years in
college that's great yeah you're two you
have a minor in group
i
am
group i [ __ ] up
group broker group
i
ate [ __ ] literal [ __ ] i
am fruit
it tasted like ass i'm
groot
which is of expected
i
am
screwed
wow who wants to [ __ ] a heartfelt
apology with a twist ending
just makes you horny as hell i guess
what culture is the groups have maybe
that's
maybe that's on the court it's just
because you're from boston uh
i was going with the fertilizer tree
approach but make it about my hometown
thank you very much right the fertilizer
was right there so much boston we
haven't even brought the despicable
patriots into it yet now
the armor wars uh production company
name is acid pop now filming under acid
pop productions llc go ahead and hire
them sometimes production companies will
have a nod to the plot of these films
lizzie hill from the cosmic circus was
speculating this could have something to
do with the soda stan lee drinks and the
incredible hulk film we'll have more on
that in a bit but does anyone have a hot
take or theory on what this might mean
i mean
i think you know not to get go inside
baseball but like pretty much everything
you ever work on they have the working
titles for their stuff and usually it's
just something relatively close to
what uh is going on or it's something to
completely
uh
fool you like i mean or or it's
something supposed to be like a cute
knot i think remember uh
solo a star wars film was called red cup
mm-hmm i believe me a redstone
club
upside down is the duffer brothers also
i see you thirsty hooligans in the chat
okay if we get to 150 maybe i'll explain
more about what koi's talking about
it's all in two weeks you guys just
didn't do it happen i just oh my god
dylan goes
i know i do believe that the super chats
are on a minor delay so i don't think
that was amazing that was incredible
timing
uh we have another group swear
uh
i think do you want to go further into
it do we need to go further
i think the lure
laura is that he yes in fact is an ass
man i don't know explain more please uh
i
am group
oh
i love ass oh my god i
am groot
all i eat is ass
i am ruth cover his eyes a simple ass
i root a
all right but i also like breasts we're
going to call it there we go
we got to go there again
not a shovel on twist that time that was
just like a nice post-credits scene
in the universe definitely makes sense
in universe please i beg you all to stop
giving us money now uh
baby groot is we gotta put him to bed
but root after dark went there
one thing we know about koi is he beats
cheeks
go back to beats cheeks now
[Laughter]
just because we've had some pretty
disturbing group this course so far does
it mean we're not going to talk about
the adorable
the sensational i will say surprise of
the summer for me how much i genuinely
treasured every moment of i am groot the
james gunn recently tweeted that his
show fits in his own in its own little
continuity saying they're canon to
themselves i think which is you know a
pretty typical james gunn vague tweet
but marvel has put them on disney plus
in the 616 continuity so i think it's
fair from watching all this that it fits
pretty firmly in earth 616. now since
marvel's mcu timeline on disney plus is
always wrong it's always confusing
no offense disney but you know what you
can't do everything perfect maybe hbo
max's timelines are perfect and that's
where things are going right for them
here is where we think in the mcu
timeline these episodes fit in this is
thanks to of course this is uh a bit of
a bootleg or not a bootleg breakdown
whoa what you're stealing from breakdown
was my show on this channel i ran two
fantastic episodes and then was never
seen again this is where we're talking a
lot about eric voss's breakdown by the
way dylan thank you again we're gonna
keep it going keep it grooting keep it
gruden all right fine i'm gonna say i'm
gonna swear this time and eric will
translate for me okay
i am groot
sometimes you win some i am groot and
then sometimes you draw i am groot and
when you draw
you shouldn't ever lose the lesson i am
group
to [ __ ] your enemies real hard i'm
grooved
every chance you get
[ __ ] hard [ __ ] long i
am
groot and don't stop till the cows come
home i'm groot
or to the manure settles i'm groot
or leaves fall rapidly from the trees
i'm groot under which you shouldn't
stand when there's a lightning storm i
am groot
goddamn or a tsunami why are they in
florida i am groot
or
on the planet zinu i
am
grouped
all and i'll never lose the lesson
always win the war that's right thank
you very much like sun tzu thoreau a
little florida man that was a journey
going on
a journey guys i can't help it i am who
i am uh people have said that i am the
uh i am the voice of my generation you
are but i'm nine thousand years old so
what generation that is uh only the
history books they'll say
uh so let's talk about
all right here we go sorry okay so the
first short we see groot's first steps
that's the name of it and we believe it
takes place shortly after the volume one
post credit scene according to the
galaxy volume on the first film and 102
the little guy we think that takes place
between volume one and two our reasoning
for that is the milano is still intact
right okay the blondo's that mono crash
lands on bear heart during the opening
of volume two where half of the
guardians are picked up by egos egg ship
remember he's surfing on it freak and
the other half are captured by the
ravagers which quite frankly sounds more
fun to me i gotta be honest it seems
like the ravages are getting into some
more nasty stuff than ego ego's like i'm
gonna like have a one-night stand with
every planet but the ravagers are like
we're having a one-night stand every
night with whoever mr ravager if you're
nasty that's right now episode 103
groot's pursuit
is during guardians of the galaxy vol 2
we think the eclectic ship was captured
or contained
by yondu so we think it was in that
eclectic ship
104 group takes a bath that takes place
between volume one and two because once
again the milano is still intact so it's
no it's not the benatar yet now 105
magnum opus my personal favorite i think
everybody you know has a little soft
spot for this is this one with rocket
yes i love this one this place this we
think this takes place during volume two
on the quadrant of a small getaway ship
detached from the eclector okay so this
is kind of all in one and two now
we have some mcu canon questions and
implications here guys we have the elf
comic from 1988 it's an actual marvel
comic again thank you to eric voss great
breakdown make sure you check that out
it's uh it's a perfectly i think
contextualizes these five episodes
without making it seem like we're trying
to convince you that these are earth
shattering to the mcu cannon i think
it's a very it's a very digestible great
breakdown from eric anyway
so
now that we know this elf comic exists
it's an actual marvel comic that in 1988
came out for humans to read
what comics can exist in the mcu and
what can't because theoretically any
existing mcu character that the world
knows about could have a comic book but
not before their public heroes not
before they come on the stage and
presumably have their their name because
a lot of movies superheroes it's kind of
funny they the characters don't get
their name of their character like
they're they're i mean do they they
don't call
um
uh
clint barton hawkeye very much do they
they just refer to his name as hawkeye
on his like case files they call him
clint they all call him clint like yeah
yeah so it's like and it took scarlet
witch like six properties yeah
exactly that's a better example they
never called pietro maxim off
quicksilver right they just shot him
which made sense for the fastest man
alive that's right of she can't dodge
bullets but he can turn time back i
guess i don't know whatever okay so what
do you guys think what other superheroes
can exist in uh in the mcdonald's or
have comic books the obvious ones cats
in america because they use it like you
know to further his propaganda and help
all that out yeah and we know like in
the fox um uh x-men movies like in in
logan there's action figures there's
comics of the x-men yeah isn't there
comic books in scar i want to say uh
black widow i feel like there's a rack
of comic books comic books and miss
marvel okay so that's the big thing that
i was like because even she makes like
fan fiction so there's technically
a world of people just writing their own
individual comic books based off of the
events dear god we're 25 away from
another group i don't think we can
handle this there's too much
there's too much chaos call the horny
police officer
just brings it out of us you guys
the tree um but yeah i feel like
everybody technically can get their own
like version of a comic book i just
don't know particularly like scenes
where they're straight up like reading
one yeah i i hope they don't like to be
honest one of the things i didn't enjoy
about logan was the bringing in the
comic mythology yeah it felt weird
because they did like some things that
felt like uncanny x-men but also not
enough it felt like it was a
inherent continuity well they left this
the the one scene between the the kid
and uh and logan on the cutting room
floor where he's like the saber tooth
exists yeah he's holding the action
figure but it's like a marvel
animated x-men anime series actually
that's another whole like medium and
universe and logan's like yes he does
exist the kids like i thought you said
those were all made up and he's like not
him he's not he was it's just weird to
throw that in there yeah and i hope that
marvel i mean personally they might be
able to handle it a bit better because
it's longer form but i'd rather not tie
in a mess of mediums about mediums
unless it's deadpool like i like the
meta awareness but you have to make it
meta aware in order for that continuity
to work right
yeah so
so yeah so i mean it's just i guess the
difficult execution of like is the
character identifiable and popular
enough that the world of mcu-616 would
manufacture and publish and distribute
yeah comic books so like eminem comics
yeah eminem and punisher timothy m m
rapper here's an m m punisher co-lab i
need to go and eminem and archie has a
comic too
prince has his own comic book i believe
on the dc in print out probably part of
his deal with doing the batman
soundtrack now on the back of this comic
is an ad for pingodorche
which is uh clearly uh it's just an
easter egg in the film but we remember
that is the
soda pop
that stan lee drinks that has a little
bit of hulk blood in it now we have uh
marvel teasing a film for thunderbolts
we have she-hulk coming up we have the
uh uh acid pop title for armor wars
uh could we see things like uh uh other
things from that film coming back like
we have tim blake nelson's character the
leader out there somewhere empty has
more about this if you want to search
our channel about what tim blake is up
to really quick me and mt do inside
marvel that comes out i think i don't
know when
it's out it's um mt's video oh where we
talk about what the possibilities of
this are and i'm probably going to spoil
them also right here i got a video on
real rejects about all the cameos that
might be in shield
we're dropping off
and then head back here and stand this
live stream uh but but i i think live
tyler might come back to shield that's
all my theories i want i was okay so i
just rewatched the incredible hulk like
yesterday and i was like i don't want
her coming back
is that weird well
are we just having her play betty and
just not be attracted to him not have
jennifer walters be a part of like his
bruce banner's past and incorporate that
way you care about her earlier and maybe
haven't seen the two of them so that
endears you to bruce banner and
therefore jennifer walters new take by
having her talk to betty that way it's
not just okay because i don't want just
hulk and her training to be the only
interaction they have so i'd love to see
like family element i think a cool way
to do that is bring in liv tyler okay i
like that now i got a question for you
guys we're getting all these kind of
hulk adjacent we're flirting with the
hulk we know like there's all the red
tape of the hulk being a universal they
have them having the film rights but
let's face it at this point marvel
studios it seems like if they want to
make a movie with a character they're
going to get the deal done feige's going
to go and make an offer you can't refuse
does a standalone hulk film which
they've always kind of been like that's
just not part of what we're doing does
it start to make a little more sense
here is that the perfect goodbye to
ruffalo for spending you know 15 years
as this character or ever like is it
does it make sense to give him his own
movie as part of phase six or something
like that what do we think about that i
would love to see another hulk movie for
a lot of the people that think hulk's
been done dirty like i i personally see
them as two different things i know the
incredible hulk is technically canon but
the whole movie that norton is very much
what i saw as a trilogy of hulk movies
they talked about the sequel being a bit
of a walkabout who's going to be like
studying meditation how to stay calm and
i really wanted to see that existential
hulk i think that the first movie not
doing gangbusters kind of curbed that
forever and then if you'll notice they
recast someone who's more of a team
player not in the actor's sense in the
hulk sense when you look look at ruffalo
he's playing the hulk off of people
almost all times it's almost always
reactionary and it's always a good thing
like the tony stark interactions like
the buzzer all those things in avengers
is hulk as something to show opposition
in concept and therefore use that hulk
as the avengers foil they never let us
really have hulk as an entity that we
dove into personally again the closest
they did was the black wooden stuff it
didn't work for me so i'd love to see
the people that wanted to see the hulk
get one more movie maybe he learns
control maybe he trains she-hulk maybe
it evolves to the point where he thinks
he's in total control and then something
happens that costs them all of that
control and we get that rageful hulk for
one last movie we get maybe an immortal
hulk movie we get something that like
appeases the hulk fans that feels
slighted but we also let mark ruffalo
not be inauthentic to the portrayal he's
gotten so far but i think you'd need
your own solo movie to really have that
story told i don't think that's what i
want to get in any time i don't think
it's going to happen but
that's i would love it i would love it
but i think we were just too far yeah
wait do you think they'd ever do a hulk
disney plus series and maybe do like an
existential i don't know
i think that's what they're kind of like
i'm hoping yeah
they're like
which i i don't like him having to share
like we got thor ragnarok and we're like
oh he's finally good to see playing hulk
and i'm like this isn't enough and then
now he's kind of sharing the screen with
she-hulk and i think we're gonna get
into that not like completely accidental
crisis but like him being like you don't
understand in she-hulk well what's hard
is the characters so powerful that it's
hard to make a movie like what's gonna
fight abomination what's gonna fight
like what he fights is always like
another unless they go
and this is someone i was going to bring
up but got e mcgaze said it too i would
love if they introduce wolverine by way
of a hulk movie like who do you have
that fights the hulk that's going to
feel is awesome have hulk go to canada
on a walkabout have them going on an
exit central journey third act is
wolverine introduce wolverine that way
give lauren a tv show have a wolverine
tv show chet over the course of decades
not having time to the x-men the last
episode is him about to go meet the hulk
and then later on bring him in the x-men
that way it's not wolverine the x-men
like the bryan center movies were i am
out of breath ah that that would be
incredible now we have once again
unfortunately reached another groot
swear we're gonna flip it this is uh
this is koi's chance for a little
revenge jessica you'll do the swearing
tyranny he said the worst things i just
trained you know what you're absolutely
right the integrity of this conversation
maintains those were all koi's thoughts
so go ahead jessica i
am grilled
the thing about cotton candy is
i am rude it looks better than it tastes
i am groot because at the end of the day
it's fluffy sugar
i am groot and i prefer ass oh
i am groot so i'm a more about that
milky way snicker situation
i am groovy so if you're gonna find me
in an isle at the candy store
i am you know where to look
oh my god
all right stop everyone stop we're not
taking any more super chats
i'm not acknowledging them now
one last thing for god's sakes on i am
groot let's talk about that drawing uh
of the guardians that he did at the end
it was so sweet a sweet little group and
obviously it's uh him uh remembering the
sacrifice that you know tall adult group
saved the lives of the other guardians
at the end of volume one now
james gunn is on record saying
that the groot in volume two is not the
same group as the group in volume one
they're the same species the flora
colossus but this implies that they
retain the memories of their ancestors
especially if they're a direct you know
sapling a little branch off of it is
that possible
are we are we on board with that
i can i can buy it yeah
stranger
entities exactly
there's also the possibility that's been
a story right like there's also like
what if they were like hey what you come
from
we want to tell you about where you come
from there you are i just ripped my
pants
i am groovy
but like a story from like i'd love if
there was a family element of the
guardians which is what they are and
maybe they told him about the group he
comes from because they do that would be
really sweet like rocket like just kind
of like telling him the story because he
does care about him we know from from
episode five of this or the short the
fifth short film rocket just can't stay
mad at him he loves him like he's this
little toddler disobedient toddler that
is so sweet speaking of so sweet all you
super chatters out there we want to
thank graveyard his go his garbage pail
kid named depraved gourd can we can we
scroll up on the super oh we didn't
refresh did we god the prep for this
show was abysmal today uh
who else i saw dylan our boy dylan was
giving us some super chats caitlyn gave
us a nice big super chat i know our boy
joe in atlanta gave us a super chat but
he's been ripping on me about his stupid
baseball team that had to change their
name because they were racist so we
ain't celebrating that film juice always
in there causing havoc filmed you saw
chaos and they did and they dumped
gasoline on it which is uh they want no
harassment right now since timon has yet
to be acknowledged on earth is there a
chance neymar will crush it to pieces
with his scene oh come on
with this scene man he got that [ __ ]
film juice you did
you definitely have the right juice yes
all right uh frey girl got in there our
girlfriend girl koi stop flirting with
me he can't help it he just loves eating
ass
uh a lot of i am groots in there we
thank the super chats let's also get
let's let's catch up on these polls all
right
how much moth gideon do you think we'll
see in mando season three the answer
uh overwhelmingly a few episodes cameo
get 71 percent yeah i mean that that
kind of feels like dinjarin and and uh
and uh and grogu are they're gonna be in
every episode everyone else you might
get two
three if you're lucky now this one
interested me which canceled dc project
are you most disappointed to see go
green lantern core 32
static shock and superman close behind
it supergirl getting no respect perhaps
because we just had five seasons of a
supergirl tv show you're the better yet
either like we're supposed to meet her
in you know the great fugitives movie so
like we'll see if that resonates with
people that's a good point and we have
which approved dc projects are you most
excited for peacemaker season two
blue beetle coming in second black
canary rounding it out by canary come on
justice for black canary i make up that
19 that's right
those are all just people trying to get
on jessica's good side we all just found
out what she's into so
all right now
do you think acid pop means anything no
51
yes 48 this is the kind of staggering
data we collect on the break room
that honestly teaches us very little
about anything and it's just a huge
waste of everyone's time thank you for
your vote this is not a metaphor for
real voting which you should do you
should get out there and vote vote your
conscience vote twice if you can okay if
you got a dead relative register them
and do that vote as well now
speaking of powerful greens
we want to thank our friends at athletic
greens today the bank can you hand me
that bad boy i'm telling you about this
little magic powder right here i said
coy oh i think he's a boy
jessica disrespect even if you thought
you heard that why repeat it
ag-1
this magical powder i'm telling you i
told you i'm back in the health game
baby i've been chugging ag ones in the
morning lines your stomach makes you
feel full gives you the nutrients i went
on a hike on monday even after i had to
work late who makes you work late on a
monday people like philip molina okay
they say stay in and you work until the
work is done and i'm like but i gotta
hike with my baby doll i had a hot ass
lady ready to hike anyway
i still met her we hiked it was great we
got a goodbye hug it was pretty asexual
to be honest with you now can we scroll
back because i need that information
still for some reason i thought you
already said it there's no need for a
complicated cocktail of costly
concoctions just a copy of a.g in your
tummy and you will get feel get you
feeling healthy wealthy and wise or at
least it'll make you like a
it'll be like a convenient insurance to
make sure you get all the good stuff you
need in a day
here's the good news everyone to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do
is visit athleticgreens.com
break room again that is
athleticgreens.com
break room you know the name it's in all
caps type in break room you type in
something else i break you okay so take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
i love you
now all right tommy drago i must break
you that's right i must break you
if he dies he dies now
ernest not that kind of magical powder
um we've been having a good time so far
we've been learning a lot about each
other i think one thing that people have
noticed in these videos is i don't talk
enough it's time for mandatory fun
all right
okay what the i am
what kind of half-assed
support by my friend
real friends of mine on this show
treating me like i'm trying to run this
train
into the station
that was worse
that was somehow worse wait why were you
you talk louder than what that was i was
seeing how much i could bring a
lowercase exclamation point you charlie
browned me
you put the football back up and i went
to kick it
guess what
it's time for the segment that no longer
has a name
each day i gather three people i don't
give a [ __ ] about it
hey wait a minute i don't give an i am
groot about and i make them engage in a
challenge of my choosing now
i was so much happier when i wrote this
now i don't want to read all these happy
words
do you want to try calling for the
graphic again no i am brutus charmed us
all with baby groot dancing drawing
possibly committing genocide you get it
it was cute stepped on all those people
whatever the hell they're called nylons
nylors gordy's grips programs
anyway based on the initial reaction it
seems like a no-brainer that we're going
to be getting more of these sweet sweet
shorts however time is passing
children grow for every season turn turn
uh so i think next uh season two of
these shorts is probably gonna be
teenage groot so i've asked all of you
i've assembled us in the old break room
writer's room to uh pitch some story
lines
for groot season two
team groot i'll go first okay
here's my episode
teenage groot finds a pack of badoonian
cigarettes on a mission with the
guardians
he sneaks into the bathroom of the
benatar to try one but accidentally sets
the smoke alarm off alerting a shocked
and disappointed mantis she can feel his
shame with her antennas
groot gets it talking to you by the
other guardians of the galaxy all except
for rocket who slingers behind silently
staring at him like an angry father
rocket then forces him to smoke the
entire pack of cigarettes in front of
him to teach him a lesson
everyone else leaves the name of this
episode leaves no pun intended
the name of this episode is groot's
forest fire groot's forest fire okay see
that i see what you did okay now who
would like to go next you get one whoo
hit the graphic again
[Laughter]
tommy is screaming for it his own
graphic that's right there's a ringing
comment
resonating back at us those pipes and
those pipes
feel it no
who would like to go next i'm done
that's it i want to get them i got i got
one okay
everyone's first day unless it's about
what i don't want to hear
all right guys
that's a different tommy's so
disappointed
all right it's time for groot to take
his space road test so nebula has agreed
to give him driving lessons as she is
want to do and after nearly crashing
into several asteroids and a cameo from
sylvester stallone and rosie mikey
rosenbaum and the other ravagers nebula
quits in frustration opting to blast the
road test proctor with a laser
and forging groot's space license wow
that's awesome hi jinx ensue and this of
course
groot gets a
barking ticket nice
mine's called group runs a train no
joking
hopefully this is 18 or 19 year old
teenager yeah he's got to get oh he's
13.
and he's trying to figure out what he
wants to be he's an adult he's got some
sap coming out of it he's got the
charlie brown christmas tree
you guys are filthy filthy filthy
mongrels and i'm gonna finish what my
nice story that's what alpha it's about
teenage group meets a cool group of
creed teenagers who dare him to do
increasingly dangerous tree activities
after they dare them to steal captain
marvel's helmet groot decides that they
are the wrong crowd which leads to the
creep bullying him drax saves the day by
viciously murdering the creatines this
title of this show is called groot's
green age wasteland oh
you did say i was concerned you said
creatines you said cool group of
creatines
that's cool that's interesting
creatine
we're going to drug test everyone before
the last episode i've got some i've got
some theories no tomorrow
okay eric bring us home dear god all
right
my teen groot episode concerns a teenage
group who's been very quiet and private
for a few days oh boy so a concerned yet
annoyed rocket barges into his room only
to find group polishing his branch
to a video of bob ross painting happy
trees oh
yeah rocket is disgusted to find pollen
all over the place
covering the room every square inch in
the room including on the leaves that
are suspiciously frigid oh
some crunchy crunchy leaves on the
episode title of this teen group episode
is groots feeling sporny oh my god well
we're all going to hell
hey
guys
uh go ahead and vote on which one is
your favorite if you dare you're
probably gonna end up on a watch list of
some sort
all data is collected by the fbi at the
end of our shows we turn it in it's part
of my court order brought to you by
expressvpn
yes now all right we've got time for a
few questions let's go through some
super chats now
let's see can we keep rolling i'll do it
i'll do it myself no you're going to
upgrade okay
all right so we can take we can also get
some normal chats yeah send us some
normal chat questions
anything up in that dock would be great
we've got just a little bit of time left
ask us questions now dylan again thank
you dylan bodie for supporting the show
today we truly appreciate it also
caitlin we appreciate you too
uh tony kevin
coy your shirt is making me so happy yay
that's great news it is a great chat
commentary right there come on everyone
go eat some pockies no we're not eating
today we're taking a break okay i'm
sorry we're not using
the other day
what do you people want we're gonna burn
holes in our esophagus okay
oh this is yes ron sortino this was a
good point
longtime fan appreciate that any chance
and our crew will be making an
appearance at new york comic con in
october we don't have any plans to yet
however not you okay
jessica has confirmed she won't be there
in new york i will perfect i would love
to go to new york comic con the best way
uh other than our own investigating the
possibility of going to these
conventions is to tweet at these
conventions saying you want new rock
stars there so that we can uh you know
we can do more than just uh show up and
walk walk the floor we want to do live
shows you know we want to do panels for
you guys and we're working on that but
let them know and also let's see moulou
know he needs to come on the break room
let dick cavett know that he needs to
come on the break room individually
he has the show very much he's 85 years
old and he is and he and he's been
called out on this show by brandon so we
are going to have him back now graveyard
my boy sent us some uh he wants more
chest there come on graveyard
work with us you and film juice i swear
to god we're going to have to put you on
our uh our vips our very important
pieces of garbage
trash bags
now
uh did we get the results on that poll i
think eric is a runaway
leader oh i'm feeling spawning
yeah no that's a win people love horny
group
that's right
okay a lot of just really concerning
things in the chat more than anything
what happened to the sokovia courts i
don't know
i thought we were gonna get personal
questions now
could kingpin be in sheol good question
i think anyone could be in chio we
actually that's a good teaser we are
working right now on a bit of a fantasy
football league but fantasy she-hulk
where we will be making predictions and
based on those predictions we will be
having standings there will be a prize
you guys might be able to join in but
it'll definitely be
everyone here and are your other
favorite hosts and other new rock star
personalities making their predictions
for she-hulk
some people have seen it so they'll be
cheating everyone else has not seen it
and it will be they'll be the integrity
you would expect from a tom bechtold
production okay i hate to do this koi
don't you say a damn word uh my video
that's a breakdown on kingpin showing up
and she-hulk comes out on sunday right
and something tells me the real rejects
may have spoken on no no
so crazy i'm austin long appreciate your
super chat can't wait to get your
tomacon poster and headshot we are
working on that now if you sent in we're
getting those shipped out we have here's
the thing a lot of egos a lot of people
we had to ask people to autograph stuff
and guess what you ask people around
here for autographs they ask for money
here comes jim you have a question from
our sort of mailbox yeah
okay sure yeah
wait are you gonna hear like physical
mail like is there a letter i thought i
thought there was he just
did he just ghost stuff
yeah are you guys ready for it i've
actually got a question for you guys
just believes never see it yet
producer john's got a question for us
all right
hey what's going on guys big fan of the
show
um
my question is
that no one seems to have asked yet is
uh
from miss marvel who is cam'ron's father
they didn't cover that at all so it's
very uh
very intriguing to find out if you guys
have any theories on that and if you can
ever see him show up in future series or
so hmm all right that's a good question
i'd say most obviously answer palpatine
yeah
somehow he certainly somehow
crosses yeah it crosses into different
shows i mean that'd be a cool way to
bring in like an og
or something you know because i do think
he's gonna end up being a mutant i like
the idea of also um this is just for the
uh the series not for the comics her
being able to create an offspring
without the help of anyone else um i
feel like she's powerful enough that she
could and we don't know much about the
gin or them in the
behind the veil and i'd like their
technology to be advanced enough that
she's like yeah i created my son i
didn't have to use another solo dolo now
just because we're almost
rounding a corner into home here how
close are we to another groot slayer
dodson i know we've gotten some smaller
super chats in recently and i feel like
we've got to be just
the kittens whisper away from another
groot tirade and i'd love to send the
show out on a proper floor colossus uh
262 no no no we're at 250. so we're at
we're we're short about 38 and sorry
just getting updated on the big board
now
uh we've got it's jackson pollock all
over that room yes good call back to
guardians of the galaxy one jackson
nicely done good pawn quinn the pole oh
yes the pole eric won resoundingly
i think this is one of the
greatest routes in the history of
mandatory fun 58
the rest of us all getting an even 14.
yeah great consolation prizes insane my
story was amazing
i thought every single story was written
expertly uh all all four of you or three
or four of us showed a tremendous acumen
for writing and creativity with those
and whatever happened those should be
rewarded yeah i got it we'll wrap up
hey
kenisha
denisha massey always there for us
tanisha we love you she says let's go we
want to thank everyone for watching we
want to thank athletic greens and their
beautiful ag-1 formula for sponsoring us
all week don't forget to check us out on
discord we're taking your voicemails
guys just like you heard played here
medics i see you coming in with that
five bucks we think everyone we always
say keep it gucci tamuchi but for now
trash bags we're gonna send you out with
some group tirades you ain't never seen
before another one from dylan daryl and
thank you again i am groot
i am groot i love you guys i am your
trash bags but it's from my heart i am
groovy and that heart is full of trash i
am gross so when i'm saying trash i'm
saying heart i am groot there is no
spoon i am group and i love you i am
groot that is all you guys can feel free
to swear too i am groot i said we'd all
go out
i am
i am group i don't watch myself
[Music]